so i want to be smiling all at you but
the lights are very bright up there so
i'm just squinting at you so forgive me
um in a moment i'm going to ask you in
fact no i'm going to ask you now
when i give my talks i like to get a
photograph a reminder that everyone's
happy so i get that at the beginning of
the talk before the end of the talk and
maybe switched off uh so i'm going to
ask for smiling happy waving hands and
faces at me and then i can put this on
my blog afterwards so please hands up
and wave say hello excellent brilliant
that's great thank you very much
all right nice
so
i'm talking about
successful data science projects um
lessons from 20 years of my career uh
trying to find ways that i failed so you
don't need to fail
and some successes in there as well and
we end on a nice positive note uh with a
recent story
uh right so
what do i care about this well it turns
out after 20 years of working in the in
data science in general um
i really care about seeing smart people
do interesting things and have a have a
good job good good work in academia
doing well with their lives i get really
frustrated when i see people doing
things that just don't pan out for all
sorts of reasons and i've done plenty of
things that haven't panned out and it's
incredibly frustrating
and most of us don't like talking about
our failures
i've got a newsletter i'll put a link up
for that at the end and i'm talking
about successes and failures that i've
had and the lessons that come out of it
and then when i've been talking about
some of the successes at one point uh
one of my readers ricardo came back and
said hey and it's lovely to hear these
positive lessons and we can learn a lot
from the positive lessons but what about
when things aren't working so well i
thought well actually i've got this
keynote coming up for pi data budapest
maybe i should talk about some of the
failures so i'm telling a version of
this that same story uh here so i was
very happy to uh to be prompted to talk
about the failures in one's career
rather than just the successes
so who am i uh so i'm an interim chief
data scientist so i run my own company i
go into companies previously i used to
go and write the intellectual properties
so i'd go and solve problems for
companies doing all of our classic data
science work i still do a bunch of that
but typically now i go in and i help
teams to succeed so i help the teams to
figure out how to write the right stuff
particularly get the teams to think
about asking the right questions not the
question they were asked to solve but
maybe the other question the one that's
actually valuable to the organization
which maybe doesn't require any big
solution maybe just requires some so
asking some sensible numeric questions
about how things are working but let's
ask the right thing and then use data
science as a technique if that's the
right technique uh to go and do it and i
love doing my machine learning i love
diagnosing and i i've written a book
with o'reilly second edition high
performance python i love my high
performance i've got a course on that i
love talking about that i've got a
course on successful data science
projects so lessons from my career on
how not to fail and i've taken a bunch
of those lessons to put in here because
i love talking about this stuff so i am
still technical but i see so much more
we can get value out of what we do by
thinking more as dylan was saying in the
previous talk thinking more about what
the business needs what the real
objectives are um behind the uh the
problem that we're solving
i'm one of the founders of pi data
london here so eight years ago i think
it was eight years ago we had our first
conference and it's grown up to this
wonderful event and even with our two
year break we've still got a wonderful
turnout here which is brilliant thank
you very much for all coming along uh
please remember to go and thank your
speakers and the sponsors and the
volunteers and the non-focused staff
because it's all volunteer time that
brings this all together
um and then i help from the the meet up
with our 11 000 members you're super
welcome to come along and join that as
well of course
uh and uh some of the client names at
the top yeah they're clients that i've
worked with they're not the clients
featured in the stories that follow i've
protected uh the guilty afterwards so uh
how does data science work in
organizations um some of you may have
come across the underpant gnome sketch
from south park uh so cartman and others
have discovered that someone's stealing
their underpants uh they're not really
sure what's going on they track down the
underpant gnomes and they say what are
you doing why are you stealing our
underpants and then we say well we're
collecting underpants and then we're
going to profit
brilliant how do you profit well then it
all gets confused there's a big question
mark in the middle and it's a classic
hack and use trope do something question
my question my question mark profit
and i think in data science so we get to
this thing where well look we just we
got this data science problem someone's
told us to do the data science we're
going to go and get the data and then
we're going to deep neural net the big
data and do the data science and we're
going to profit at the end of it and
it's going to be glorious
but i suspect that actually a lot of the
time when things don't work out uh it's
because we've asked the wrong question
we've thought about this the wrong way
and so here i'll tell a couple of
stories where i've thought about things
the wrong way things have worked out the
wrong way and then i'll give you a
reflection on this
at the end
so i think we fail a lot i know i failed
a lot it was difficult to say there i'm
a consultant i shouldn't fail i should
always succeed for my clients but i
think we all fail a lot so i'm going to
ask that uh how many of you have been
associated during your career with at
least one project failure
okay so all of you brilliant keep your
hands up if it's at least two project
failures
okay so most of the hands down right so
great we've established that we all
failed brilliant we're all failures
excellent uh when i've had more than two
um
i've been doing this for 20 years you
collect all of those war stories over
time and you realize actually there's a
bunch of reasons why some of these
things evolve but we don't talk about
failure very much um this is one of
three talks out of 40 at the conference
talking about the
non-data science statistics machine
learning mlops side of things so it's
less than 10 of the conferences looking
at this but this is the thing that gives
you the project that's worth a million
or not a million if you get it wrong so
i think this is an increasingly
important topic to talk about talking
about so i'm super keen to talk about it
afterwards if you want so i think it's
not all about the technology of course
the tech is important of course the
stats is important but i think it's not
all about that i think there's a lot of
human factors that come into this that
cause things to go wrong at various
stages and a lot of them are easy to
learn from and you don't have to repeat
my mistakes brilliant you can take some
easy lessons
so let's uh wind back in time this is
very early in my career
this goes back uh
15 years
13 years quite a long time ago
i had a client they were doing
automated price discovery of products
online so that when you visited a retail
store in your browser and you found a
product they could tell you the same
product was cheaper elsewhere and they'd
get an affiliate fee from directing you
there
very sensible thing
this is when amazon wasn't quite the
behemoth that it is now and there were
many alternate sites to go and buy your
things from amazon was one of the
players for sure
so you take some metadata from lots of
sites about the same television
or lipstick or deodorant or white good
for your kitchen whatever it was huge
data set um and then do some natural
language processing and and 15 years ago
nlp wasn't quite so well written about
as it is now you couldn't just go to
media or stack overflow and find the
answer for how to do this uh
scikit-learn is 13 year old years old
and i was using it so it was at least
about
12 11 years ago um so back when we
didn't know how to do really good
nlp on our data science programs to
figure a bunch of this out as i went
um
we had to go and we our little team had
to go and figure out how to find the
most similar products because every
website has a different version of that
product they spell it differently
describe it differently they've got two
descriptions up there
so you want to find the cheapest one
great
i talked to the client um this is the
problem we agreed the specification
verbally first mistake i shouldn't have
done that should have written it down so
we agreed a specification verbally it
made sense small tight team working
together collaborating we all knew what
the problem was
i got them to spell out exactly what the
problem was what the data was how this
was all going to fit together so that we
couldn't make a mistake very important
not to make a mistake
and so i built up a gold validation set
explained to them the importance of
having a gold standard we could work
against before we went onto a larger
data set built our bag of words model
using scikit-learn did our similarity
measures all pretty sensible stuff
we made great progress everything was
looking pretty good so what could go
wrong this is one of my early solo
consultant projects it's all going
gloriously brilliant
then they gave me some more data and it
was weird data and we know enough about
nlp now that whenever you scrape data
off the world we get all of the horrible
stuff we get um strange
different windows versus utf-8 encodings
of text we get misspellings we get
strange punctuation we get slash ends we
get zeros and o's confused and we just
get all of the rubbish that you get off
the web fine
the annoying thing was the client hadn't
told me about this and when i said to
them look we've got this new weird data
set that's quite different in nature to
the previous one even though we've
agreed to solve this one problem
uh why has it changed no but oh well
we didn't want to scare you off with the
hard data set
so although we gave you the one data set
actually there's two data sets and now
we're showing you the real problem
oh that's that's kind of crap right
because we can't solve this problem how
does the human solve this oh the human
can't solve this we can't we can't
actually figure this out the data's
awful um but
your data science magic no no data
science magic i'm gonna have to walk out
of here now and so that was really
upsetting even though i tried my hardest
to make my client explain to me what
their problem was they they told me they
told me all of the problem but they
still segmented it into two and then
gave me another problem later when i'd
proved the first bit
which was nuts we could have figured out
the beginning that we couldn't solve the
hard problem just not done the thing in
the first place
um
so that's really painful that's bad news
we don't want to be doing that the
critical point there is we gained a lot
of knowledge but there was only one
project to work on we couldn't take that
knowledge and pivot to another project
and then reuse what we learned the hard
lessons we'd learned we had one thing it
failed
end of deal that was it and so if you've
got nowhere to pivot to that's bad news
i've worked in what we'll see on some of
the slides um when you've got options to
pivot you have some options
what's an easy solution here well write
a specification okay if the client's
still not going to reveal the problem to
you you've got a bigger problem but at
least if you've got the thing written
down you've talked about it you've
expressed it you've had managerial sign
off that you've written everything down
i've got my examples nothing has been
hidden from me and you get everyone to
agree this is the entire problem
then and you've had a human explain how
they solve every step of the problem on
all of the data that you've been
provided with you're probably okay so
when i teach my success class i get a
specification like this and we talk
through it and there's nothing super
magic in there's a bunch of topics you'd
all agree look pretty sensible you
haven't got to use all of them
what is the business need that's going
on here what is the dollar value behind
the business need do we understand why
the business makes money or saves time
or whatever it is
who has the responsibilities where does
the data come from what are the
uncertainties in the data what risks
might i see in there what assumptions
can i make what would the timeline look
like it's all boring stuff right i'm not
solving any machine learning with this
but if i go and ask these kind of
questions i flush out so many
uncertainties and then my project runs
more smoothly and is less likely to
explode so that's easy we just write
stuff down by asking sensible questions
so that's one lesson
here's another lesson uh so another
story um i did i've done a bunch of work
in insurance now over the years i really
enjoy working at insurance interesting
industry uh you think it's pretty
sophisticated but typically insurance
organizations they're very risk-averse
they're quite conservative they're not
sophisticated some of the biggest ones
are they've got very nice data science
teams uh the tier two tier threes well
they've got data science and they've got
data and then the smallest one's
definitely not they've got excel and
some old data and that's about it but
it's an industry that needs to get more
efficient and better understanding of
its data and it's its customers its
needs its evolving market
so i was working in a team um i joined
when it was 10 and we got up to 25 or so
across a couple of continents uh
revolutionizing one of the large
insurers brilliant um there was a
difficulty here we had a boss who had a
very very hard challenge he had to go
and get large chunks of the business
aligned with the needs of data science
when everybody didn't want data science
they wanted to be conservative and do
the same old thing without taking big
risks because risks mean failure and
then a non-risk-friendly atmosphere
that's bad news so he sold success
he sold success before he'd seen the
data
he'd sold success before he'd seen
whether the business recorded the data
that you needed to solve the things that
were sold as success so we as the data
scientists were given projects this will
generate a million dollars this year for
that client on that vertical go and
solve it i think brilliant where's the
data you can find it it'll be over there
somewhere in excel or something
and some of the times there was data and
some other times there was good data and
you could actually build models that
outperformed the actuarial models and we
made money brilliant and a lot of times
there wasn't data one of my glorious
projects involved several months tracing
it back to the point where we discovered
you know the reason why the data's not
in the database is not because nobody
even types it in it's because nobody
scans the paper document that's stored
in an offsite facility but you do data
science right you can use the magic to
get that data off the paper that's over
there somewhere
and do something with it and no of
course you can't um
and then bringing that organization
along that journey to realize that
actually you are backward and you've got
to upskill data storage putting things
in a database making sure the data is
there that's just a long old painful
journey but we're even told you're
delivering a million in three months
because that's been signed off already
before you even got involved in the
project it's kind of terrifying
but there was an upside unlike the
previous client engagement where i only
had the one option here we had multiple
problems in multiple departments and
multiple verticals lots of different
opportunities to pivot so even though
some of the projects didn't work we
learned a lot about how to solve these
problems and who had good data who
didn't have good data in this large
organization where the data lived who
was collaborative who put resources up
front and so we could pivot around and
then we got more success that way so
another lesson here will be always look
for opportunities to pivot and if you
can't find pivot opportunities and
there's some high risks be really wary
about wading into that could be really
exciting until it goes horrible around
you so try not to be in that uh position
and then talk to the client talk to the
humans in the organization i spend so
much of my time teaching data science
teams to go and
talk to the humans elsewhere in the
business because they know what their
problem is they know if they're
recording the data that they need to
actually automate any of these solutions
they know if they don't bother typing in
the data or if they outsource it to
someone who types it in differently
every month because it goes out to the
cheapest organization that will do this
outsourced work they know what's
feasible they know what the actual
dollar value is behind all of this so go
and encourage your teams and yourself go
and talk to the business and find out
what we can do with all of this and if
people are really reticent about
committing that hey you could automate
anything with the data that we've got
don't commit to doing a project i've
learned that one sadly a couple of times
because i'm always optimistic i always
try to be so optimistic with my clients
and then it turns out sometimes you just
get beaten around the hill with a stick
a few times before you realize if the
client if the people who have the data
if they're not optimistic about it well
probably there's nothing there that you
can actually operate on as a data
scientist
in my course i talk about the data
maturity model i think this is a pretty
interesting way of thinking about
organizations it applies some startups
through to the the largest organizations
so and there are many data maturity
models out there this one's quite nice
because it's just got four simple
pillars
growing up that maturity uh stack is
difficult
so if you've got a data apathetic
organization i will never touch a data
apathetic organization they haven't
recorded their data they don't use excel
very much they haven't written things
down it's all in people's heads there's
no data you can't do any science there
no data no data science
a data driven organization does pretty
much everything by the data that they've
got stored brilliant excellent so the
man group here with their automated
trading strategies one of our sponsors
that's an example of that data driven
organization that means they've solved a
lot of their problems already and
they've got all the data they need
brilliant they're in a very mature
position
i quite like working with the data aware
in the data critical places because
that's where teams are coming online
they're getting their data together they
do have data
or they've built teams but they fail to
deliver a lot and then i can help them
unlock a bunch of that and that's really
interesting to me and i found working in
organizations as you move between
different departments taking data
science as a siloed activity perhaps out
to different teams some teams well
actually they
they're they're critical already they've
got all their data they're making
decisions
they want faster results better
prediction others are less less
sophisticated long as you've got a way
of judging that you're going to think
about what i do with it and can i help
this team do they have what i need so
that we can move forwards in a sensible
way that's a good mental model to have
here's another example from insurance
with one of the teams that we worked
with and this is one of the successful
projects in that previous organization i
mentioned they had the data it was
brilliant they were doing this my
colleague was doing the same thing as i
was doing i had a project where no one
was even scanning the data from bits of
paper he had a project where the data
was beautiful it was in the database it
was timestamped it went back years it
was consistent and clean it was
wonderful
he built a machine learning model on it
random forest it worked great so we can
actually outperform the existing
technology in the company we had metrics
to show that brilliant
we took it to the client the client was
one of the underwriters so they were not
data science oriented but they had a
good mathematical background and they
didn't trust this solution they didn't
trust this new data science team we
hadn't delivered
output of value to the organization yet
so the trust was low and my colleague
bless him he was drawing random forest
tree diagrams printing them out and
walking the clients through a tree
structure one tree at a time explaining
the value of an ensemble and an average
guest that comes out of the ensemble
and trying to walk them through all of
the detail explaining it and he had some
huge like anal printouts showing these
streets and it was a beautiful effort
all points there for effort um but i
could watch my client just switching off
just thinking i have no clue what this
means and i do not care and i don't
trust this things and so we step back
and say well hang on a minute so first
of all rather than explaining all of
every single tree how about the
colleague and i just go through some of
the examples and we trace them back to
their raw data sources check it make
sense and validate some of these to the
client we came back to the client and it
turns out there was some weirdness in
there and the client would say oh yeah
that's because that client's special
they're in the other table you do know
about the other table don't you so i
know we didn't know about the other
table great so we go on iterate a couple
of times find all the other data sources
and improve the model and we improve the
data integration brilliant and we go
back with the clients and we start using
shap as one of the diagnostics and just
explaining individual predictions they
would ask some pointed questions and
sometimes they go yeah i don't really
understand that judgment but it's you
know i kind of get where we are on the
positive negative scale and the factors
behind it that kind of makes sense then
they asked us this really hard question
about one of the examples they knew when
we brought it up and we talked about it
for a while and they were yeah
yeah okay i get it i trust it now that's
good
that's my client and you've explained it
and the model explains it the way i'd
explain it so therefore i trust this for
everything let's just deploy it and it
was a beautiful moment in trust winning
it taken several weeks to get there but
having that visual diagnostic process
and going through the raw data with the
client discovering all the bits that
we've missed and going round and round
in a loop but really
figuring out what the client mistrusted
they didn't know what this black box was
doing and opening up that black box and
talking them through one step at a time
at a high level that they could
understand with a nice shapley diagram
was a really nice way to get them on
board with trust
we segue sideways another one of my
clients was working in venture capital
with one of the top tier venture
capitalist firms in the uk and they said
hey we want to investigate our data we
don't normally investigate it please
come and do some magic well we're not
doing that magic discussion i hate the
magic discussion um partly because i
don't know your data and also i don't
know vc so i'm ignorant i don't know
your business domain
let's talk about what you actually need
and where you want to go and so let's do
a de-risking project check the quality
of your data we identified many issues
of course they hadn't used their data
that's always a good proxy for and my
data is awful so the data was awful we
had to go and fix it up that shows no
progress to the client so that's a
difficult one to sell on but then you've
got to do that before you can do the
next thing of course and then we got to
build some models uh later on um it's
always good to stop your client whenever
they ask you to go and do some magic and
just say we're not doing magic magic's
crap we're not doing that we have to go
and understand what we what we've got
but also what you need and is it
feasible with the data that we've got
one of the nice things when you've got a
clean data set so that's the insurance
example and the venture capital example
is you can go in with baseline models i
always go in with the simplest baseline
model that we've got uh yesterday we had
the executives at pi data session and
one of the uh one of the attendees was
talking about getting a model deployed
early on in the first couple of weeks
with a random guest in there so not a
model that's learned anything but just
getting a model process deployed that
makes a random guess so we can go
beginning to end and the thing works and
we can see it working
super important i'm massively behind
that now and i've had examples like in
the insurance industry
months being spent on an outsourced team
building a random forest model that was
going to be amazing no one was ever
quite sure if this thing was actually
working and there were no diagnostics no
i'm sure on the data but we went through
it and okay the code kind of looked
alright and it was it was weird but
months have been spent
then someone said yeah but if you take
the average of the data set you get less
error than if you use the machine
learned model on the same data set that
was a huge embarrassment and that led to
some arguments because with three months
invested the bosses wanted to deploy
deploy the model and i would argue but
if we deploy the model that does worse
than just having a mean guess of the
data set the client's going to figure
that out right they're going to then not
trust us and we're a young team who
hasn't got many successes we can't
deploy a lie
and that led to some arguments um and
it was just an awful way for things to
go um
flip that over to my venture capital
clients and there they had a bunch of
rules that different members of the team
would use to evaluate their data to find
companies that looked interesting for
investment i have a very large set so
it's a prioritization problem
and they would say like my my uh my rule
is the best i've got several rules the
rank the right companies at the top and
everything else we discard and i could
implement those rules using a bit of
numpy and a template using the template
classifier from scikit-learn and then
put that alongside a five-fold
cross-validation or time series
cross-validation on the time series data
set against the logistic regression two
input model and show that my model
outperformed theirs for various reasons
and we could build it up and that bought
trust which is really really nice so i
massively always argue for going with
the pipeline that does something first
of all even if it's a random guess and
then start to encode the clients rules
and the clients ways of thinking in as
the next thing
and then going for a mean regressor or a
default classifier and then actually
beginning to do the data science
afterwards on top because that way
you're quickly showing incremental
progress all the way through and we've
got the tools for this in psychic learn
so it's really easy it's a couple of
lines of code you have to write and it's
often overlooked
the venture capital client did have a
downside that really didn't work out
quite so well
one of my more painful stories
one thing i learned about venture
capital
is that when you've got 10 000 companies
uh coming in in europe in a year that
need evaluation you've got a small team
evaluating them they want to find the 10
investments they want to invest in so
it's a one in 1 000 success rates you're
expecting to see there and they want to
reject all of the other so they want to
reject
990 of these companies and then just
find the 10 that are good
first of all vc i learned it's a very
people driven business no it's not in
the data they've got some data but the
interesting stuff is not in the data
it's in the the people's relationships
so that was bad news once we discovered
that but there is interesting signal in
some of the data and some of the data is
even consistent so actually you can
extract some of that signal and do
something with it
the people who go and make all the calls
and try to figure out which companies to
contact they're the junior associates
they are paid by success so they're
effectively high ticket sales people
boutique sales people selling chunks of
five to 50 million pounds as an
investment in exchange for your equity
they get paid if they find the right one
or two companies to put that five to
fifty million pounds into
so they do not want crazy ian turning up
with some strange machine learning model
saying don't do it your way i've got
this new way that we don't trust the
tool that might reduce your chances of
finding your one or two down to zero or
one or maybe just zero um but i need
this for you for your feedback rights
and if i get the feedback i can make
this better in one day you might get two
or three rather than one or two nobody
wants to make that first leap and
particularly at certain crunch points in
the year like christmas when they're
trying to close all the deals and that's
when i was doing my testing really
trying to push my testing out with the
client
uh so that was really terrifying and i
got my contract got terminated there
it's the only contract that's ever been
terminated around me i was really upset
about that i actually ran to the pub and
insisted my friends buy me beer that
night um
i got feedback from the cto later on
that one of the deliveries i made was
used because it had one of the companies
listed highly that was a signal that
then went on to validate one of the
investments they made so there was
positive outcome for the organization
but it turns out when you're in a
problem-poor environment there's a very
little chance of success
very little relevant data and an
organization not using their data in
that kind of fashion already just the
chance of success is low
and i'm an optimist i love a difficult
problem so of course i had to go and try
it but in terms of actually doing well
it was a silly thing to go and do it was
really really hard and it didn't really
work out
so again try to avoid situations where
when your gut says actually it's just
really really hard walk away from that
one go and find a problem that's much
easier hopefully one way with some
simple rules you can go and get
something of value and then with a
progression onto a nice uh deep learning
or whatever it's going to be you can get
an even better result that's valuable
for the company but don't start with
something that's just really
ridiculously hard don't make that
mistake please
so uh one of the ways to get past this
of course is to get your clients
involved early
always be delivering early and often and
again get that pipeline going with the
random guests are in there that does
something beginning to end
give them something that makes them look
cool
i found this to be very empowering i
haven't got to find the insight that is
better than what the client's inside is
because the client is the person who
knows the business domain but they
haven't got an automated way of getting
that insight out if i can encode a chart
a histogram uh whatever it is a table
that validates something that they know
they've never been able to prove to the
organization but i get the data i get
automatic buying at that point i get
more trust i get more flexibility to go
and do interesting things so help the
client look cool early on probably
that's pretty pictures that they can
show to their boss everyone is empowered
by pretty pictures i would always push
for that
and then simple models linear models you
can always explain a linear model with
five terms for somebody and explain
which way the uh the coefficients are
going positive negative certain
magnitude there lots of pictures help
with the client to diagnose the problems
find the problems in the data that
builds trust because you've identified
those problems and then quickly deliver
some value to them so that they look
cool if we can do that we buy political
points we buy time for ourselves and
then we can go and do the cooler more
interesting hard work but that has to
come later
another joy from the insurance industry
i wasn't working on this one thankfully
i just got to step to the side of this
and shake my head in shame
one of my colleagues made a successful
random forest um
solution for a machine learning problem
great um and then and this took some
months took a while to get the data to
understand the business domain to get by
and everything was good everything was
good everything was good and then it
said yeah we can't do python we need sql
only so my colleague then by hand
rewrote the random forest as best they
could in sql as the deployment strategy
but there were no tests there was no
validation we hoped they transposed the
rules correctly as they typed by hand we
don't know so was it right and that's
that's awful um and we could have well
we could have avoided that by just
figuring out that we had no deployment
opportunity but that's a silly
deployment opportunity we just shouldn't
have done this project in the first
place but it's one of the projects that
was sold by the boss who promised the
big output
and then we because it had been promised
we had to go and deliver a thing and so
it was just painful all around and it
wasn't obvious at the end of it once it
had been deployed whether actually it
was working for the client and it was
going to use this thing
and so always
can we actually get to a deployed status
is there a question there
it's recently enough that it's still
painful in my memory
after the cloud that would presuppose
that the client was using a cloud
uh
but that's presupposing that the client
had a cloud
right insurance industry
conservative likes boxes in a corner
they can look at and they do use the
cloud sometimes
and some people are allowed to also use
the word cloud in conversation sometimes
but not everyone and certainly not the
data science teams
and lots of industries are backwards
right they're they're quite conservative
and then getting everyone on board with
what we need for data science uh is hard
uh in some organizations lots of
organizations
so what would be a solution here well
plan
plan for operationalization and so
planning early for that especially for
your v1
in your specifications where you're
developing your plan with your client
think about what they would need to
deploy a solution and if it turns out
they've only got some weird vdu green
screen thing plumbed into a very legacy
system with a mainframe behind it and no
one knows how to integrate into it we do
not build a clever xgb model and hope
that we can superimpose the results onto
the screen because that's madness we let
that department upskill itself over time
and come up with a modern system that we
can integrate with uh because otherwise
we cry
um so and also yeah sit with the client
figure out how they work now i've had so
much success by sitting with clients
watching them type details in and asking
them pointed questions about how do you
figure out which field you're choosing
there oh just kind of guess at that one
all right i'm going to use that field
why do you type into things over here
when the data is clearly over there
those systems are disconnected and they
often have duplicates or errors between
them okay i want data screwy over there
then but we only figure that out by
talking to the clients seeing how
they're operating um and yeah don't
forget i mean you all know this but a
corporate could take six months just to
get a machine before we figured out what
goes on to that machine um which is yeah
more tears so let's end on our happy
note um in the abstract i said uh i'll
tell a story about making a million
dollars for a client actually we had the
evaluation a couple of weeks ago and
conservatively optimistically we've
decided two million is actually what
we're delivering so i get to cross out
one minute and put two million up there
um for this recent client which is
brilliant i'm really happy about this is
like one of my biggest best successes in
my career so i'm super happy about this
so i get to be enthusiastic now uh so
this is working in insurance i'm looking
at fraud and over billing
so payments that are duplicate invoices
that are paid because two invoices came
in by mistake or two invoices came in
because somebody decided to copy one and
submit it again and try to commit fraud
and then all the weird and wonderful
ways that this branch is out um lots of
uh different interesting things here
there's a fraud team in the company but
they're hobbled by non-automated tools
so what can they do with all this so
what do we do we de-rest early we spent
a couple of months discussing lots of
project ideas we found positive examples
there weren't many of those at the
beginning it inverted our ordering of
potential projects once we'd found those
examples the less interesting projects
pop to the top because we had examples
and the other ones we didn't we assigned
value so we could add to that
prioritization we agreed a delivery
schedule based on what we learned um we
had things like improving the sql
debugging some sql super boring yeah we
found a chunk of a million there
counting how many eye tests you have in
a year you have one or two you don't
have 52 someone who has lots of my tests
of the year is probably doing fraud so
we count no one was counting this kind
of thing
percentiles a more nuanced version of
counting
lots of discussion with the clients
improving the sql because we had a
problem-rich environment we had many
opportunities to go and exploit the
knowledge gained over here again over
here rinse and repeat an idea find more
value that was brilliant we did have
some machine learning in there great um
but that wasn't the the thing that got
us the value it didn't got the value was
coming up with those rules in the first
place and it got to the point where the
bosses boss was writing their own bi
solutions to demonstrate new things that
they thought existed so that we could
capitalize upon those ideas so we've got
a whole team and layers of management
bought into this it was really really
really a beautiful outcome i'm really
really happy with it
but then we get a new problem with that
client uh it turns out when you've got a
tiny fraud team and you're flooding them
with new examples of fraud because
you've got automated systems you've
still got a small fraud team so you've
got to grow the fraud team that'll take
a couple of years so moving up that data
maturity model and getting the
organization mature enough to use these
things is hard work and takes a lot of
time
uh i've asked colleagues
what they find important for
prioritizing projects and dealing with
new projects and new clients and they
give me rule sets like these totally
right a bit different from mine you'll
find that if you talk to other seniors
around what do you think is most
important everyone's got a different set
of these things but it turns out find
your seniors see what rules have been
encoded for your organization and make
sure you're asking all of those
questions in the projects that you're
working on that gets you past so many of
the problems that you might face
and so i think this boils down to have a
clear written specification for your
work before you start
try and de-risk as much as you can know
your business need and the value and
then dylan was talking about that in the
previous talk uh coming up with good
business metrics incredibly important to
figure out actually if deep neural nets
or machine learning or anything is
actually valuable in the first case know
the risks if your gut feels tight about
anything go and de-risk those risks
before you write any code don't do the
type
do the talky-talky go and figure out
what's going on because otherwise you're
going to waste time and then it's all
going to go horribly wrong and then know
how to deploy it right at the end
before you start the project
so
i don't think we have to go and steal
underpants i think we have to go and
find good puzzles and think about the
whole puzzle set and a whole bunch of
that is human factors and then we solve
the puzzle deep learning neural nets
machine learning stats might be in that
solve the puzzle piece but maybe not
maybe we're just solving a problem it's
easy to solve with some
equations in excel and that's totally
cool as well
and then we get the profit at the end of
it
so i'm talking about a whole bunch of
these things uh on my newsletter it's
free to join if you want to join in not
a number all the backlogs up online on
that site so you can go and see the
stories that i've shared there if that's
of interest to you i've got a bunch of
uh all of my all of my past talks are on
my blog
and if i've taught you anything
interesting i ask after every talk
please send me a postcard i have
physical postcards that i put on the
wall they're a physical reminder that
i've helped teach people something new
so that's interesting to you send me a
message i'll send you my my physical
mailing address and send me a postcard
i'd love a postcard they make me really
happy
thank you very much for listening
thank you ian that's great um we have
some time for questions a few
who's minutes sorry i haven't got my
glasses on are there any questions
there we go
this is the bit where you get to watch
me run around the room
hi thanks for the great talk um
what would be your advice for dealing
with like a
moving target problem in a company so
like
mike i have an example for instance i'm
sort of managing this project and then i
had to go away on leave we had agreed on
what we were going to do then i had to
go away and then i came back there was a
meeting that happened to like talk about
the progress and so on and then suddenly
the specifications had changed because
now the client is like well actually i
want something else
so like i'm trying to like go back to
what we had agreed and so on so what
would be your advice to dealing with
like changing
um expectations and goals all the time
and so on
so that's really hard
um i mean i
the reason i write things down and the
reason i get senior management sign off
before we start anything is because
otherwise i'm the one left crying
because it always come back to me as the
consultant you're the reason this didn't
work uh and yeah you did change
everything halfway through right yeah
but
obviously
um so no i insist on a fixed
specification now the specification also
can be a living document and so we know
what we've what we think we want we know
what the metrics are we know what the
solution might be we know what the data
should be we know what the risks are and
then in my specification dock i'm happy
to very happy to call it a living
document and iterate filling in the
blanks
but the thing we want to deliver is
still the same thing that we want to
deliver and if someone changes their
mind there i'll say all right great
that's a new project let's start again
and yeah do you want the cost of
starting the game um and then that leads
to some awkward conversations but the
alternative is i i got it wrong and i've
learned over 20 years i don't want to be
the one getting it wrong so yeah i would
just say you've got to dig in and say
either we're doing that project or we're
starting a new project which is totally
reasonable but we have to treat it as a
new project and we've learned a lot so
we can start it faster but it's still a
new project got got to scope it de-risk
it assign who's on it and all the rest
of it all again
it's that feasible yeah okay
was there another question
um oh that is five too
is it a quick question yeah okay go
ahead here we
let's go mike for the video oh okay i
was
so the question is
if you're in an organization and the
data science team is currently
underutilized how what steps can you
take to sort of fix that
um
good question uh before i answer do we
need to swap the speaker yeah yeah so is
the next speaker here do you want to
come and step up whoever that is are
they in the room
um
so let me just unplug
this
oh it's not that person oh
okay well they're not here um but i'll
answer that question then and just pull
that out there we go um
how to use an underutilized data science
team great question uh walk around the
organization and learn what the business
is doing uh what's valuable and where
the problems are
i try to teach my data scientists to go
and talk to the business in all the
different departments
and just say what do you do does it work
um what could be done better what
problems do you have
and then after a while those that are a
bit more sociable will come back with a
laundry list of problems many of them
not interesting for the data science
team lots of engineering technical
whatever problems or people problems
lack of market share problems whatever
but then maybe you go off to marketing
or to sales and say hey i've heard about
these problems are these interesting to
you they go yeah we do a b tests on
these tiny groups and we get these kind
of noisy results back that appear to be
random um and you go well that's because
your test set sizes are tiny um how
about i help you do a proper ray b test
on a marketing split test with
appropriately sized groups and some
stats behind it they go oh we never did
that sure and then you find the new
problem when you go and solve that so i
think being adaptable is key there but
going off
becoming internal consultants going
around shopping yourselves around
finding problems
and finding valuable work for yourselves
i think it's an underrated activity as a
consultant i have to do that all the
time so i teach other data scientists
yeah go and do this you've got great
skills sell it
thank you great question all right thank
you ian um
so uh i'm gonna step outside now if
anyone wants to carry on talking about
this please come outside and if you want
to carry on the exact conversation from
yesterday step outside and we'll carry
on thank you very much for having me
you